so finally Ghana wants to know why are
there no children in a shy why what why
are there no children in a shy yes
well because you know a shy is a dark
and dangerous and mysterious place and
of course that's where does she get that
information she got that information
from one of my fake history books all
right
apparently yes and who wrote the fake
history book but maester of the Citadel
where is the sit at all on the
westernmost edge of the world where as a
shy on the easternmost edge of the world
it's a little bit like a medieval monk
writing about what was happening in
Vietnam they're not necessarily the
greatest experts but you know you may
find out I don't plan to set any scenes
in destroy at least not in the present
book but you may find out a little more
about it in future books we do have one
character who's been there of course and
that's Melisandre so in the chapters
from her thought you may occasionally
ever think back on some of her time in a
shy okay so again ask you about that all
that he is if you live in the universe
of A Song of Ice and Fire
what religion would you follow and why
what religion would I follow and why
well that's an interesting question
you know the predominant religion of
course is the faith of the seven in the
world of Westeros so there's a certain
advantage to following that because in
any society if you're part of the
predominant religion it has social
advantages you're accepted you're part
of the major group you're respectable if
you follow a different religion you're
not so respectable
on the other hand no lissandra's
religion
they actually seem to have magical
powers bringing people back from the
dead and things like that that's a
powerful selling point I've often
thought in the real world if there was
one religion where you know they had
actual magical powers and could like do
miracles on command and all of the
religions have miracles
you know 2,000 years ago or 500 years
ago or they're all in their holy books
but none of the people around currently
can do those things so Mandi will
promise eternal life but everybody in
the movies dies so I think a religion
where they had actually magic that
worked would become a very popular
religion in whether it's in the real
world or in Westeros of course there is
a certain grim intellectual power behind
the faith of the faceless men Valar
morghulis all men must die and you know
all men do die so it doesn't seem to
matter what God they pray to in the end
they're dead which would seem to
indicate that the god of death is a
really really powerful God and maybe one
that usually should pay attention to
okay thank you
[Music]
the next one was sent by my aunt Eliza
Jaramillo and she wants to know if any
of your character is going to die of old
age I believe she has not been paying
enough attention because I believe that
Maester Aemon has already died of old
age oh you're
[Laughter]
so Monica when Macarena asks did you
ever imagine your story would have such
an impact on society
practically becoming a cold reading
becoming what becoming a cold reading
cold reading again I'm not I'm sorry I'm
not understanding okay so if you ever
imagine your story would have such an
impact on society faculty becoming a
cold feeding no a cult okay yeah no I
you know whenever you write a book you
hope it's successful and I've had books
before it I've been successful I've had
books that have been failures I've had
books that have been critically
acclaimed but commercially
but no one could have anticipated the
the scale to which Song of Ice and Fire
in Game of Thrones has has filled the
world I I told the story the other day
at dinner I took a cruise a few months
ago and we visited a number of cities in
Asia and in we stopped on the Isle of
Borneo and we visited this tourist
attraction in Borneo where there are
there are five tribes that have gotten
together and they whole they've all
built replica villages of their their
ancient tribe you know the longhouses
and and you walk through the jungle and
the hills with your group for the from
the bus tour and as you visit each
village they demonstrate the way they
cook and they have you know local people
there who are dressed in period costume
and each of the tribes had their own
distinctive costume
and two of the tribes were were
headhunters and cannibals and three were
not and they had people walking us
around you know it's a tour a lot of
tourists come there you stop in Borneo
and you have to keep the groups moving
because there are old new buses coming
all the time so we always had a couple
couple of the the people the actors I
guess you'd call them who were in
costume were guiding the group around
and with walkie talkies yes their dad
village 3 now we're moving him along the
village for that's we're just starting
the archery exhibition and they would
they were keeping track and we had one
of the de cannibal headhunter guys who
was walking with us for four or four
hours wearing basically nothing but a
breach cloth around his his waist and
carrying a walkie-talkie and formidable
formidable looking guy you wouldn't want
to meet him in the jungle he was from
one of the headhunter tribes he was
representing and he was with us all
afternoon keeping us going and then when
we reached the end of the tour and we
were about to get on the buses to go he
came up to me I said mr. Martin I'm a
big fan of Game of Thrones so that was
when it really threw off home to me that
even the cannibal headhunters of Borneo
are aware of this show and these and
these books and if I did any doubt about
the global reach of these things now I
it's exceeded anything that I could have
expected anything that HBO ever expected
anything that my publishers ever
expected and it's it's been a thrilling
it's it's great I've I've enjoyed it I'd
enjoy it more if I was finished eating
less new books so I need to work on that
thank you